he is Barry Melrose how you been Barry
yes I've been great man I've uh I didn't
know what was 1996 when you came aboard
I thought you were a little bit after me
but no time doesn't it it does Barry it
sure does
before we get to the current state of
pucks I want to go down memory lane with
you okay because I'm sitting here in los
Los Angeles California I mean how did
you become coach of the LA Kings how do
you go from the Adirondack Red Wings and
and then go to the Los Angeles Kings how
do you with the the old fashioned way I
earned it I won in the American League
when I was coaching Adirondack it was
Detroit's foreign team and we wanted to
call her a cop which is the American
League which is like triple-a in
baseball I had a really good team and
Los Angeles was looking for a new coach
at the time and they went outside the
organization they like the way my team's
played and you know they after mission
to talk to me and and I did talk to them
and I got the job and I'm hold on you
know I got to coach the greatest player
in the world Wayne Gretzky and for three
years so it was a great time in my life
and you know it was a fun time to be in
Los Angeles also yam is making did
McNall pick up the phone was he the one
who called you Barry actually yeah he
I met him in Los Angeles I certainly
know who the Dalton because everyone
follow of LA and what was going on in
Los Angeles Bruce was becoming a very
powerful owner he was among the top
three or four powerful owners and hockey
at the time so I certainly know who
boost my dog was and then in 88 he went
and got Gretzky from Edmonton and
changed the face of hockey from that on
so I did know Bruce and I met him when I
first came to Los Angeles matter of fact
they put me into LAX in the morning and
and I met with Bruce and will be by Sean
and Roy malarkey who's the president of
the team that morning and was that the
first time I mean you're from
Saskatchewan so was that how many times
have you been in Los Angeles in your
life Barry maybe six six you know when I
came into I played there as manger of
Winnipeg or Detroit right so
probably no more than six it was pretty
pretty big city for a scattered boys
yeah so so I mean and then your gret
what was your first meeting with Gretzky
like these are questions I always wanted
to ask you in the newsroom but we never
had time so what was your first meeting
with Gretzky like very it was not well
it was a movie it was a like you'd have
in a movie I land I get the job I do my
press conferences I set it up that I
thought he wanted to talk to Wayne the
next day there was a major earthquake
that night and I was standing on Central
Avenue and I looked out my window I
think I was on the 12th floor one of
those hotels on centuries and I could
see the water and the swimming pool go
from one end to the other to the other
and the next morning I got the see Wayne
I went out up north a little bit about
half an hour's our town to hotel and
Wayne came in from LA where his home was
and I talked to him for both two hours
Janet it was hilarious
there earthquakes and so all the stuff
that went on and then Janet drives Gretz
up to the hotel in a minivan and then
she took off and then we were supposed
to talk for about an hour but she came
back and we we still talked about
another hour so I'm talking with Wayne
and the hotel about what we're going to
do the type of team we have the type of
style of play I won Janet shows and the
minivan with six kids waiting progressed
to finish his conversation with me
so they could head on home it was just
surreal a typical la meeting exactly all
you envision something in LA happening
and then you make the cup you make the
cup finals that year right 92 93 season
and then you you know it's it's entirely
possible that you're gonna be up two
games to none and Jacques Demers of the
of the Montreal Canadiens calls the refs
over and says check out Marty McSorley
stick right Barry yeah that happened
game two and it changed game two and
changed the rest of the Cup Finals
because they called him for having an
illegally curved stick yep right and and
we were winning the game at the time and
totally to playing them I don't think
one girl had a shot for the book the
last 12 minutes but they called the
stick the stick was illegal and they
ended up tying the game
with about a minute laughter and they
won Game two and all the time but still
we still went in and won one game in
Montreal and that's what our job was now
we're going home to LA we've taken home
ice advantage way to Montreal and we
would just go home and take care of
business when the two games and go back
to Montreal so that was the plan
Patrick law unfortunately didn't read
about the plan well the reason new
continued is unbelievable playing one
truth engine all the time and baby this
is five games the reason why I bring
this up Ari is because Montreal has not
won a cop since and there are there are
those who believe there is a Marty
McSorley curse that that was while
calling out a stick for being illegal is
one thing that it was kind of bad form
to do such a thing
do you believe Barry Melrose in the
McSorely curse yea or nay yea I do
believe in I do believe in karma I think
that I think that it's and dr. mares and
my friends that place is shocking but wh
am shocked my friend but you know with
the calling of the stick was there's too
many things going on we always laugh
about it you know they say the ghosts of
Montreal always protect the Montreal
Canadiens well maybe the curse of Marty
McSorley and the LA Kings are stronger
than he than me a story and the ghost of
control because la is one to Stanley Cup
since then Montreal has one ending so
maybe maybe there is some do all that
ugly and and stuff going on behind the
team I love it Barry Melrose here let's
talk about the here and now now how is
Vegas doing what it has done Barry
how is how do they do this rich is the
best story in sports this what if this
was this was in NBA or the NFL this
would be the biggest story in the world
but for a team to get an expansion team
to build this team and to be this good
that we're happy living the Western
points weeks ago they were leading then
a gentleman points they were the first
team in the NHL to have five twenty two
twenty three twenty goal scorers and
they're still going
they're still winning every night
they're still playing a great brand of
hockey and if you just you know that
this is a team the north david chance to
and and arguably they've been the second
best team in the NHL all year long next
to tampa so just a fantastic story if
it's Cinderella its it's not supposed to
happen it's a you know it's a fairy tale
what's going on in Vegas the building's
packed that people love them there
they're the hottest ticket in Vegas so
it's just a great great story so you
know what happens on Cinderella is that
the midnight strikes no big carriage
turns into a pumpkin so do you do you
think that happens with Vegas I mean how
do you see this playing out I see this
playing out that I don't think they're
gonna win the Cup but I think that
they're gonna they're definitely going
to make the playoffs and they're going
to be a tough tough game they're going
to be a tough team to play game because
they're built the way you're supposed to
build a team and that excellent Flurry's
been great defensively they're great
they've got depth on defense they don't
have a they don't have an elite NHL
defenceman but they've got seven really
good defenseman and up front their
offense and their goal scorers and their
forwards as good as any in the league so
you know I this team's for real this
team is gonna be a player come play and
in the 15 hours of live trade deadline
coverage beginning Monday on the NHL
Network at 8:00 a.m. Eastern Time which
team do you think needs to have a big
Monday to have a shot to throw their
their name in the ring with Vegas
Nashville Tampa etc well the LA Kings
already been dizzy they've they went out
found two players already Dion Phaneuf
was traded there he's got three goals in
the last four games they just created
for Tobias reader last night from
Arizona a good player certainly he'll
help the depth on that team so LA is
already out and running and they're
gonna get Jeff Carter back eventually
hopefully before the season is over
so because that guy will really make a
difference for the LA Kings Ola is
already ago you saw the Rangers last
night trades out there to the devil so
the Rangers are going to become sellers
this year the Devils are a team that has
to do something they did the Islanders
have to make the playoffs for a number
of reasons number one you know you've
got to think that something like this
has to happen if they're going to be
able to keep Johnny Cabarrus as a member
of the Islanders so the Islanders need
to make the playoffs to get some
positive ways and and get Johnny Tavares
think that seriously of staying with the
Islanders so you know Pittsburgh I think
we'll make a deal because they they
always make a deal at the deadline and
he ends up your ideal that helps them
they want to sound tough they're
certainly going to try and win the third
the capital might need a steal because
they're struggling bed right now but you
know in the West every team in the
central could be trying to make a deal
because there's such a tough evenly
matched series and and you saw Nashville
last any seventh they ended up going to
Stanley Cup final so if you get the
playoffs they have a chance again itself
most sports that don't you know it's
pretty obvious who's going to win but
you know really if you make the playoffs
in the NHL you have a greater chance of
winning the Stanley Cup and all I said
Barry I'd be remiss if I didn't ask you
about the Olympic hockey not having NHL
players in it it just felt different
even though you know we were celebrating
the American women gold medal on the
same day as the Miracle on Ice when we
all remember when a bunch of ragtag kids
beat beat the Russians now it's the 21st
century and I kind of missed the NHL
players what do you think that we'll see
the NHL players back on an Olympic ice
anytime soon first of all rich I'm
shocked because I'm from Canada and we
didn't win curling and we didn't win
hockey no what is going on how does that
I don't know better Canada does not when
curling or hockey so right there I'm
talk with what's going on over the
Olympics yeah the NHL will be back I
think everybody wants them back I think
you know the players have been very
vocal especially Alex Ovechkin he wants
to play in Olympics I don't think me NHL
is going to miss an opportunity to go to
China they want to become you know right
on the ground floor of hockey being
expanded in China so I think
that certain going to happen obviously
disappointed with the American men and
the Canadian men you know the American
women it's such a great story haven't
won since Canada Grenada you know Gary's
runaround carried the gold medal around
many years ago so I I think it's I think
it's great what America did and and
really the amazing thing to me about the
American women and the Canadian women
the American women are much more skilled
in the Canadian women you it's it's you
just watch them play the style of play
is so much different though can Canadian
women are much more physical much more
of a grinding team where the American
women are very skilled team and are very
dangerous offensively so this year they
were able to get the goaltender they won
in a shootout and it was a fantastic
hockey and there was a it rich it I
don't know if you watch the women's game
it was a great hockey game I'm not
talking men women I don't care if you if
you hate women talk here or don't
believe in women's hockey it was a great
hockey game it was intense it was fun to
watch and I've become a fan of women's
hockey over these Olympic it was a great
product on yes I agree with you Barry a
thousand percent I just wish it just
didn't end in a shootout you know rich
we all hate you guys I hate you those to
determine anything major you have to
have an irregular cease imal okay with
that realization I I got off my soapbox
okay that's my they have a game like
that that much passion and the
annotations and what have also seemed
left on the ice to have it end in a
breakaway is shortchanging both teams
not just the American on just the
Canadian team is shortchanging both
things that seemed shoulda went until it
was a goal scored yeah there they were
all you know those are all champion
hearts that beat inside those chests
they don't want to play the light drop
you know so did Barry I love and
hopefully they okay Barry love catching
up with you let's chat let's chat more
when when the playoffs begin and we
start grinding in the corners around
here okay anytime at any time give me a
call you got it that's right that's
great Thank You Barry Melrose NHL
Network an ESPN again the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience